es ist der alltägliche wahnsinn in
diesen zeiten der pannen ein hilferuf
erreichte niklas schneider oberarzt der
intensivstation der münchen klinik
schwabing durch hat die leitstelle grad
gut bewegung
69 jahre alt 6 liter sauerstoff im
augenblick 39 temperatur vielleicht hat
durch den erst mal schauen wir euch ein
notfall für einen kubik patienten wird
dringend ein intensiv bett gesucht hier
auf stationen sind allerdings alle
plätze belegt das problem ist der
notarzt steht jetzt draußen irgendwo mit
dem patienten vielleicht im notarztwagen
und muss in die klinik anfahren und die
leitstelle suchten bett es gibt im
augenblick in münchen kein freies
cockpit intensiv wird mehr deswegen gibt
es eine gute belegung das heißt auch
wenn wir sagen wir können eigentlich
nicht versorgen kommt der patient und so
geht das seit tagen mit wachsenden
inzidenz zahlen fühlen sich schneider
und sein team mehr und mehr im
hamsterrad eine schicht folgt auf die
nächste überstunden sowie so der
ausnahmezustand ist hier die regel wir
sind alle sehr erschöpft mittlerweile
ist frustrierend die patienten sind jung
wir haben 100 prozent im augenblick
ungeliebte patienten bei uns und das
macht man natürlich traurig weil das
überwiegend schon unfälle wären die man
hätte vermeiden können ein junger mann
anfang 30 ungeimpft kämpft und sein
leben seit tagen sein zustand wenig
besser werden trotz intensiver
bemühungen bei aller professionalität
situationen wie diese gehen sie mal das
war dann schon schwerer gehabt wenn die
patienten so jung sind der patient ist
noch deutlich jünger als ich es bin und
er hat noch so viel vor sich ja und wir
wissen nicht ob der patienten diese
infektion wirklich überlebt im november
2020 noch vor der impfung hatte sich
auch der 48-jährige mit dem virus
infiziert bei einer patientin hier auf
der intensivstation der verlauf war zwar
mild die folgen umso gravierender
erschöpfung lähmungen
gedächtnisstörungen es hat wahnsinnig
lang gedauert bis ich einigermaßen
wieder auf dem auf dem domberg und weg
für kranke nie wieder haben
und das ist für mich natürlich auch ein
persönlicher kampf dass wir dagegen
ankommen nur wie bei täglichen
neuinfektionen von 40 oder 50 tausend
wächst die sorge vor einem kollaps bei 1
hier die nächsten wochen wird es einfach
sehr irgend werden wir werden sehr sehr
viele patienten werden sehr sehr viel
denke ich auch tote haben es ist
zunehmend belastend weil wie kein ende
in sicht ist das einzige was sie retten
würde sagt niclas schneider sei der
zusammenhalt im team durch die
vergangenen monate hätten ihre spuren
hinterlassen bei allen hier wir merken
dass zur emotionale dinge dass sie uns
mehr treffen und diese selbst
schutzmauer die man um sich herum
aufbaut die bröckelt und die
brauchen wir aber auch so ein bisschen
um das ganze professionell machen zu
können um sich selber daran kaputt zu
gehen und dann muss es ganz schnell
gehen wieder einmal der patient für den
kein intensivbetten ganz münchen zu
finden war wird nach stunden und doch
auf die station eingeliefert platz wird
geschaffen wo keiner ist sie alle müssen
nun noch mehr leisten wenn man sieht wie
man hier versucht mit allen kräften bei
intensivbetten noch zu schaffen und
einen patienten irgendwo noch an eine
beatmungsmaschine zu bekommen da denkt
man noch die pandemie ist nur hier drin
sind hier drin statt und draußen denn
dass hitlers keinen menschen mehr und es
hat dieses gefühl mit den auswirkungen
der pandemie allein gelassen zu sein was
die menschen auf dauer hier würde machen